hello and welcome to this video playin
hah gay for the millionth time so okay
now I get to play money for idea idea
what would I and recommend it in my
video series on the unusual openings of
course I have forgotten everything so I
really don't remember what was going on
there I think he a six was good i'm not
mistaken yeah at it that's pretty ok for
black let's see um what to do here push
it before it's going to play three I
guess yeah maybe just take it ok so I'm
not sure a three if this is a weakness
or not but maybe I can provoke the
smooth no I cannot ok so what does
castles I guess
so what now can try to yeah can I can do
fancy things on normal things I wonder
at Bishop before was such a great idea
may I should've just put it on d6 it's
not quite clear at the moment what this
Bishop is doing on that square
okay I tried to provoke some weaknesses
him let's see if I can do that I wonder
if age 30 that I'm slightly surprised
about that he's actually allowing this
it's not a big deal but didn't see a
particular reason why why he would um
yeah why he would play into this okay so
um Bishop t6 maybe Sam something great
that he can do FYI have 93 I want to go
at five year possible without moving the
night
maybe t4 here i don't know but i
probably have night h2 then now I
definitely have 9 h 2 let's in fact
pretty substantial threat here night a
ch2 group e one Bishop h3 that's pretty
pretty devastating i think if it hits
all night h2 and went n word then F for
our k9 edge to wear for okay does not
work at all but f5 f5 is definitely a
move him on fo I can take and play 93 or
go back I mean I'm just happy that I
have a foreign to get my my rook
involved
I don't know maybe store should go out
for him k group takes something like
that and I probably have to take but i'm
just unsure about things here okay I
have to take now I probably yeah yeah
Brooke fe1 I guess and then nighty three
that might be a journey without any
return ticket so probably night age
success to be played as a five I mean
I'd f65 it's not working for me the
other rook is just 93 so I have to go
back here Jo that this isn't this is
okay very okay unless t5 is good but he
cannot do that if i go here okay now
that this is this is nice it's a very
very nice endgame piling up on a steep
on the night on age six question is how
to how to do that I go here the night
over to e7 I'm I want to play c5 of
course this is he doing here for g4 I
know I want to play c5 without him
having d5 so this is why I'm regrouping
the night over to e7 if possible many
plays Bishop a three here
don't know I just don't know you should
buy three is not justice look ok I think
I have my doubts about all this I think
it's a small beginning then helping him
ok c 5 now right so d 50 is this g5
somehow a problem see if I've 25 95g
takes f5 this is the thing right ok I
have to play I'm also better with with
the standard looking moves let's say so
I don't have to do something so so
direct necessarily
it's just pressure pressure on deform
and white fighting against the bishop
pal still having c5 and so on yes OC
five years is there a defense to that
don't see it really don't like rook c1
maybe I ok just went back
alright see hmm yeah I see ok still not
threatening that story or anything like
that
thank you how does hard to say really
it's just three strengthened things a
little bit more Wow check I'm surprised
that this would work maybe it does check
check check check well yes defended this
it's still not great or anything but
it's not losing I think maybe maybe not
losing is losing on time but good
position I'm not like for its high it
wasn't so convincing they always had big
pressure but yeah okay well the opening
it it's okay for black there's nothing I
really fail to see the point a little
bit and playing something like that with
white you're fighting against the bishop
paired have no compensation for that
this is the center is not particularly
strong okay I'm not sure about Bishop
before maybe I should just go to d6 ok
this is this is interesting I'm unsure
if it is good but it's an interesting
tribe freeing up the f porn and
something like he cancelled surprisingly
I found oh interesting the engine gives
Bishop g6 instead of Queen age for Queen
d6 it's an interesting choice f4 does
not work h3 does not work g3 is bad due
to Queen eh6 so this system then the
engine wants to play age 5 funny
at least like that are pretty nice it
was a very good alternative and this
seems to be not that great d 4 is
supposed to be a slight edge for white I
definitely know that I probably wouldn't
have played what the engine wants me to
do it wants to give the check and go
back to the six that's very strange but
ok i'm interested in the game
continuation here ok and five was clear
and now f4 take sticks very interesting
i didn't see that at all the engine now
wants to take here because after FTX see
takes the night has no square or well it
has a squared has g3 but this is kind of
interesting like this and i win the
pawns here it's fairly nice but
interesting idea something i have not
thought about at all yeah yeah i thought
it should be maybe if I don't know it's
equal many ok but I was still pretty
happy with this because of a long-term
I'm fine yeah I'm just a little bit
behind in my development I'm pretty
stunned that the computer likes white in
this position ok it wants to play this
route the eighth and it's this an Bishop
to c5 yeah that's indeed interesting
that's interesting hmm Jim and I don't
really have a move that I like to play
here I mean this is bad simply because
of this thing and I don't like to take
but I probably have to do that I hear
why does somewhat better clearly hmm
interesting so I think I didn't evaluate
that correctly I felt like here I'm
better which is not completely unfounded
if i get my pieces coordinated and
prevent this what happened in the game
basically the game was exactly what i
was thinking what would happen but that
Bishop 83 Bishop to c5 is really strong
but he did to go for that and he just
put put his Brooks behind the pawn and
no I'm starting to take over he loved it
yeah I would this I would have liked to
play but d5 seems to be possible yeah
like night XG takes and wide wins ok ok
so this yeah only after this the engine
switches to a black advantage we should
be too still evaluated as ok yeah maybe
I never get to get so much yet it's
possible the way it it turned out also
wasn't that brilliant Chan kan jag this
kind of thing is probably equal check
this is probably just equal I don't know
but they can try to take the kingside
them are you the computers again on a
black edge but hard to say I mean it was
pretty clear that you cannot
the time but he probably defended that
rather well I mean when it was was
turning into something from black and
think he defended this okay but Bishop
83 c 5 was a lot better after that I'm
probably probably somewhat worse okay
well thanks for watching